[Music]
in best case scenario news submitted by
Kiki Smith P a young boy thrown from a
mall balcony miraculously shows no signs
of brain damage oh yeah I heard about
this [ __ ] it was a crazy guy that was
like grabbing people and throw him off
the [ __ ] balcony and [ __ ] did he land
on his ass so he pounced on the soft
area he still sustained like physical
damage though so he was he was hurled
over a third-story balcony
Dalen third story at the Mall of America
that's no bad that's the biggest mall
right that's survivable that's [ __ ] 30
feet in the air I don't know if these
stories Maryland boy wow they're saying
that he has shown no signs of brain
damage after that 40-foot drop oh my god
so from from there to like all the way
down pretty much he had to have mounted
on his butt cheeks
you know kids are also lucid stuff
they're all alike you know I mean when I
did some rush hour [ __ ] where there's
like the [ __ ] canopy that's true
because I don't know any kids with flat
butts all kinky but time you got a
little diaper butters up there I don't
know any kids with flat but anyways
Landon after his fall he's like I get
I'll put my money on this okay I know
this is a gamble but I'll put my money
on this was before the fall that looks
like a celebration picture to me that's
definitely after the fall what makes you
so sure I don't know I want a gavel that
boy's fashionable too you're looking
survived
he is fashionable he's trying to match
the headrest you don't know anything is
there after photo saving that fanny pack
save them get a parachute inside so the
family wants complete privacy and the
person that leaked this information
about him not having any brain damage
was a pastor how would he know if
there's Brandon isn't their pastor
client confidentiality
he's trying to show them that guy while
he's not Catholic
so during Easter service at the church
he said that the boys grandparents told
the pastor that like oh thank goodness
you know the prayers worked like it's a
miracle it seems like well maybe the
vitamins worked yeah it seems like his
injuries are more it looks more like if
you fell off of a bike rather than three
stories
well can we can't Witzel how did he fall
someone threw we keep talking about him
falling back really really big person no
there was a crazy guy and I was going
around throwing people on you just threw
from what I know that one little boy so
he went into the mall the day before his
name is Emanuel he went to the mall with
the intention of throwing an adult over
like he's just crazy but they're too
heavy you're not good he actually tried
is our surveillance to punish him going
Oh [ __ ] well I don't know if he
physically tried but he says that a key
that's the intention he had the day
before so then the next day what an
honest man you just randomly picked a
kid cuz maybe because I reason they're
lighter and so he just hurled the kid
over this might be [ __ ] up but I want
to see I want to see this kids down to
get thrown again and see what the proper
technique is to survive a three floor
landing to picturing someone that does
those high dives yeah like what did he
do oh [ __ ] my bad kid tripping that was
the Black Power Ranger I was going to
say that there are there if there is a
resemblance
I'll strip it a little bit yeah Zach
like Bella G well looks like he legit
looks like black it's not just you
there's [ __ ] body wall yeah I probably
heard this wrong but I heard I heard
something on the rail because I heard
about this the other day he got caught
for some [ __ ] - oh no he had a history
of throwing people on people yeah the
guy in prison that man so he had it he
had a history of like assault or
whatever what if he's just a big fan of
Judo
he just likes throwing people but it's
still wrong don't go to jail
uh no so he did previously he was
previously banned from the mall for a
year for throwing something over not
someone something so if he first started
throwing like sweaters
it started with sweaters yeah it turned
into like milk yeah then for the final
it was the human being
I remember reading that right I mean I
heard some [ __ ] like that
none of these articles but I remember
reading that he was banned from their
order from the mom you know when you're
a kid and you like to drop things from
very high places I think that's what
evolved into now like trying to throw
human well so this most recent one he
said that he went to the mall looking
for someone to kill because he was angry
about being rejected by a woman at the
mall in the past so he hates the mall
the mall the last ways I want to go on
I'm pissed
yeah especially when you're pissed at
the mall and how can you be pissed when
you smell that [ __ ] Cinnabon hits me
I'm like oh yeah time to relax mr. ant
don t son you know the pretzel yeah is
it like Aunt May's or auntie ons or some
[ __ ] that is good sugar I went to the
Glendale Galleria Mall yes certainly you
know what I what the [ __ ] was that
where's all these questions like I
couldn't remember where I was oh you
know the you know I realized young
Armenian immigrant
look like rich Taiwanese kids they dress
exactly the same do this they were the
supreme [ __ ] match at all super
new-money look it's all new money they
just they don't know what to wear they
just put whatever is expensive all they
just Frankenstein yeah yeah it's crazy
they dress exactly the [ __ ] same
there is that foreigner style though
yeah I love their track suits like it
doesn't matter if you're Asian or
Eastern European or whatever like they
all have the same taste it's like I'm
just gonna pick the most expensive thing
I see and put it on and then it's gonna
look good but I saw this one video of
this girl I forgot how much her entire
outfit was worth but it was like a [ __ ]
ton of money
and I saw a comment that said like damn
while that money you still couldn't buy
census style
it was so bad like it was like what
you're talking about but that's what
everybody looks everybody just looks
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] boy that's what it
is it's just like it you can't just put
that [ __ ] with so it's like it's that
logo that they like right so supreme so
everybody knows supreme is worth
something now so they're just like the
biggest supreme thing here and then the
word supreme shirt and they'll just have
whatever I say [ __ ] the same there's
such a genius company cuz they're shit's
probably not even great quality right no
it's just well there was a troll company
yeah they were they were really really
doping the way they did it because they
originally started off doing their whole
collapse with like it was like a skater
brand and then what they did that was
really genius and you know how they
recently did a collab with LV so they
were known for doing that collab
originally without their consent so they
sent them a cease and desist to stop
doing that right so they stopped doing
that but that's what got them on the
market that's what everybody knew them
for so after that they blew up but then
another company decided to take that
idea they go oh we're going to put Elvia
on our [ __ ] - well I'll be didn't send
them a cease and desist they'd [ __ ]
sue the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] company
tink and so but so they actually got
lucky by getting the cease and desist
and not getting sued but that gave them
enough know to ride to continually build
their brand and then after that lo and
behold LV wants to work with them
because they want to go to street wear
so yeah so they got their second and
there are billion dollar company knows I
like that supreme the Mike Tyson one
this is supreme leader with North Korean
Dobby but it is my face boy this little
boy was teaching classes how to jump
from a third-story would you let isaac
take that class from a three year old
knows he wouldn't be becomes a
motivational speaker and he teaches
classes on how to fall correctly that's
amazing you know something I don't
I'm a mall survivor I'm just saying
there's also there's also a nonzero
probability that he has superpowers and
that was how just watch Ultraman the new
series no same thing happened to get the
kid fell from like a bunch of stories oh
that's right and he was totally fine and
they're like he's special there's a lot
of Falls I had as a kid where I'm like
damn looking back I think I should have
broken something and I'm
I walked away from that I think I only
have scars and I'd like flu [ __ ] far
away from like like I hit face-first
we have video that no this is before
cameras I know it would have been
[ __ ] funny before cameras got how
like you know video counselor say other
what the [ __ ] like it wasn't as
excessively two minutes back then you do
have superpowers so did you get age I'm
six hundred years old dad crazy [ __ ]
car accent two of them actually Wow Here
I am
there's nothing wrong well I do say that
kids are more likely to survive any type
of crazy [ __ ] because their bones are
still like soft some skateboarders do
[ __ ] like this you got I think there's a
guy named Aaron which Amica Blonsky yep
sounds about right
but he like he does like to story jumps
off of buildings and he just lands well
Ryan Sheckler like isn't like everyone
else does he also take the supplement
called crack survive everything this
will be a video a long time ago crack it
to a comeback for building another dude
that was like a crackhead walking in
Skunk it is possible they have the most
exotic animal I did you know what's
crazy I used to jump from that separate
houses the part like six feet or
whatever ice to jump off those all the
time as a kid right and a moment like
three feet tall now when I'm like even
if I'm on like a stepping stool when I
come down I [ __ ] my knees hurt [ __ ] who
are you yeah I'm on this table now where
to jump down I'd be like really oh wait
probably the impact I don't have that I
don't have that balance is a kitty that
part cool role now I can teach you to
tuck out of it
you tell you obviously you eat land and
then yeah I will be that loser jump not
two feet doing the parkour Rhea did you
give a cereal on top I got it so spots
in the whole house every time you finish
it
Dubey does [ __ ] my knees hard after I'm
sitting for a really long time like
every time we go to a movie we're
watching a movie from just having them
bent like this like I need a stretch
your paralysis maybe I do oh you know
what maybe it was my IUD they told me
when they first gave it to me I'm
supposed to take some vitamins cause I
mean something because whatever it is
like whatever hormones they have it's
supposed to like it depletes it it
depletes my bone density yeah and I
never took those those [ __ ] you're
gonna take calcium I didn't take any of
those vitamins and I had that [ __ ] in me
for ten years oh [ __ ] my bones are
[ __ ] doing what she sneezes just
dislocated it actually job all the time
right now you didn't see me I was like
[ __ ] my shoulder I wanna see you give
Isaac like a high five arm wrestling or
like when they breathe
well yeah have you seen those videos let
me break there I've never did people
that break the forms like that yeah from
arm wrestling yes scary doctor yes all
right we got the water down now we just
need the nutrients - yep
[Music]
[Music]
you